in this session on go back in our key
protocol we will apply the application
of sliding window method which we did in
the last session
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to miss an update from
us
now without further ado let's begin with
the agenda for today's session
to start with we will look into a quick
recap for the sliding window protocol
moving on we will look into what is the
go back nar q protocol
continuing with some important points
regarding the protocol
and then we will also look into the
working steps of the protocol
i am continuing with some advantages and
disadvantages of applying the protocol
at the end of the session we will also
solve an example using the go back and
air q protocol
let's begin with the sliding window
protocol
sliding window protocol is a method to
share multiple data frames at a time in
a network channel
the frames shared in the network are
based on the window size assigned
beforehand in the network model
as for the last point we have
each of the frames are assigned a
sequence number for frame transmission
and also to achieve more efficiency in
the network channel
now let's look into some information
about the go back narq protocol
this protocol applies the sliding window
method for transmission of data in the
network channel
where n in the protocol refers to the
window size assigned in the network
model
as for the term arq in the protocol
refers to the automatic repeat request
which means the sender side will send
multiple data frames to the receiver
side according to the assigned window
size
and only after it receives an
acknowledgement from the receiver site
will it continue to send the frames from
the sender side
moving on let's look into some important
points regarding the protocol
as to begin with the method applied to
share multiple frames from the sender
side to the receiver side is known as
the protocol pipelining
where each frame is assigned a sequence
number for proper transmission of data
in the network channel
now let's move on to some other
important points
as we already know
the n in the protocol refers to the
window size that is the maximum limit of
frames that can be transmitted from the
sender to the receiver side before
reaching the acknowledgement
for the previous frame
and in case if the transmission of the
acknowledgement of a frame is not
received within a certain time period
then all the frames from that sequence
number are to be retransmitted in the
channel
this point is to be remembered properly
because this will be the key point in
solving a question related to go back in
arq protocol
now let's move on to the working of the
protocol
to begin with we have a sender side and
a receiver side
along with the sequence number
the window size for the network channel
and the number of frames will already be
assigned in the network
now by applying the sliding window
protocol we will send the first three
frames from the sequence continuously
which will be frame number zero
frame number one and two
this is assigned according to the window
size
after sending the frames we will have a
sliding window over the sequence numbers
that are 0 1 and 2.
after the frames are sent to the
receiver side it will use the frames and
send an acknowledgement signal to the
sender side
that would be zero for the first time
after which we can share the next frame
that will be frame number three
from the sender side to the receiver
side
after sending frame three
the sliding window from sequence number
zero one to two will shift over to one
two and three
and similarly
for frame number one we will receive the
acknowledgement signal from the receiver
side to the sender side
and then we can share the next frame
that is frame number four from the
center side to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift over
from
sequence number one two and 3 2 over 2 3
and 4.
as for the next frame that is frame
number 2 when we receive the
acknowledgement from the receiver side
there is a catch
for any network issues
the acknowledgement is not received by
the sender side
so in this case as discussed earlier in
one of the important points the sender
side will not transmit
frame number
5
instead it will retransmit frame number
2 3 and 4
where the second frame is the one which
did not receive the acknowledgement and
all the frames sent after second frame
is to be retransmitted along with it
that is three and four
to much better understand the solution
for the example we'll be solving later
in the video it is suggested that you
watch the steps involved in the working
of the go back and air q protocol again
now moving forward let's take a look at
some of the advantages and disadvantages
of using the protocol in a network
channel
for advantages we have it increases the
efficiency of transmission of frames
it also allows multiple frames to be
sent at once
and the time delay is low for sharing
the packets
as for disadvantages we have
the tree transmission of frames in case
of an error in the network channel is a
very difficult work
and it also requires the storing of
frames on the receiver side that it
receives from the center side
now that we have learned everything
about the go back and airq protocol
let's take a look at the much awaited
working example for the same
let's take a look at the problem
statement
in a given network the number of frames
provided is 10
with the window size assigned as three
and for every fourth packet is lost
find the total number of messages
or frames sent from the sender side to
the receiver side
from this question
we can get
three main parts that are the number of
frames that are given is 10
as for the window size is three
and every fourth packet is lost
let's take a look at the options
option a27 option b25
option c 22 and option d29
i'll give you guys a moment to take a
look at the question again
now let's move on to the solution
as usual we have the sender side and the
receiver side
and according to the question we have 10
frames
numbering the frames sequentially we
have frame 1 to frame 10
and then according to the question we
have window size as three
now using the sliding window method
we'll send the first three frames that
is frame number one two and three from
the sender side to the receiver side
that will be
like this
after sending the frames we'll wait for
the
receiver side to send the
acknowledgement
and the sliding window will appear on
frame number 1 2 and 3.
now the receiver side will send the
acknowledgement for frame 1 to the
sender side
and using this we can send frame number
4 from the sender side to the receiver
side
and a sliding window appear on 2 3 and 4
sequence number
and similarly for frame number two we'll
send the acknowledgement from receiver
side to the sender side
and send frame number five from sender
to the receiver side
and a sliding window appears on sequence
number three four and five
then again for frame number three we'll
send the acknowledgement from the
receiver side to the sender side
and send frame number six from the
sender to the receiver side
and the sliding window appear on frame
number four five and six now let's move
on for the next frame for
acknowledgement that is frame number
four
for this frame according to the given
question every fourth frame is lost
during transmission from the sender side
to the receiver side
that means
no acknowledgement will be sent from the
receiver side to the sender side for
frame number four
in that regards or any other frame that
are sent after frame number four that is
frame number five and frame number six
similarly frame number five and frame
number 6 will also get discarded
now let's re-transmit according to the
go back narq protocol
frame number 4
frame number 5
and frame number 6. after retransmission
frame number four will get acknowledged
by the receiver side to the sender side
that means we can send next frame that
is frame number seven from the sequence
order
and the sliding window appears on frame
number five six and seven
similarly let's move on to frame number
five
but before we do that let's count the
position of fifth frame in the
transmission order
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven and eight
that's correct
when we count the position number for
any of the frames from the beginning we
use sequence
not the sequence number given by the
question
that means
fifth
frame is at the position number eight
from the beginning that means according
to the question it will get lost during
the transmission from sender to the
receiver side
similarly
frame number six and frame number seven
that was sent after fifth frame will
also get discarded
according to the go back in a rq
protocol again we will retransmit five
six and seven frame number to receive a
site from the sender side
after re-transmission frame number five
will get acknowledged by the receiver
side and then we can share frame number
eight
from the sender to the receiver side
and the positioning of the sliding
window shift from
five six seven frame to six seven and
eight sequence number
now let's move on to the sixth frame
but according to the positioning order
position of the sixth transmitted frame
is number 12
that means
it will get lost during transmission
from sender to the receiver side
and similarly
frame number 7 and 8 will also get
discarded by the receiver side
and again applying go back in our queue
protocol we will retransmit frame
numbers 6
7 and 8.
on re-transmission frame number 6 will
get acknowledged by the receiver side
and we can share frame number 9 from the
sender to the receiver side
and the sliding window will shift from
sequence number six seven eight to seven
eight and nine
now let's recount the position of the
next frame that is frame number seven
from the beginning
and that would be
16 that means
frame number 7 will get lost during
transmission from the sender to the
receiver side
and similarly frame number 7 8 and 9 is
to be retransmitted
according to the go back narq protocol
now similarly following all the previous
steps we can complete this network model
using go back in our q protocol but this
is a work you guys have to complete
and find out the total number of packets
that were transmitted from the sender to
the receiver side
and give your answers in the comment
section
with this we have reached the end of the
session
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comments
section thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here